well Harry and Megan have demanded a
royal apology for the claims made in
their Netflix documentary The six-hour
wineathon launched blistering attacks on
Britain and the British Monarchy and the
palace is reportedly baffled by the
request they're not the only ones and as
if we haven't suffered enough tonight
Netflix released a new trailer for
another Harry and Megan show this one
promises to be just as smug as the first
one
this was inspired by Nelson Mandela who
once said what counts in life is not the
mere fact that we have lived it is what
difference we have made to the lives of
others that will determine the
significance
of the life we lead it's about people
who have made Brave choices
fight for Change and to become leaders
and giving inspiration to the rest of us
to live to lead
it's unbelievable isn't it I mean every
time I think they can't plummet new
depths these two they're now comparing
themselves to Nelson Mandela who spent
nearly 30 years in a 6x6 prison cell
really it went on to become the first
black president for South Africa
a unifying leader of true greatness
one of the well actually the the most
impressive person I've ever interviewed
in my life they are comparing their dash
for freedom to a mansion in California
where they now Hawk out their Royal
titles for hundreds of millions of
dollars
that's what Mandela did in their eyes
well to me it's unbelievable but maybe
there are some out there that believe
this stuff
joining me now is the author and active
is Natalie Collins the former head of
Royal protection guy Davis and talk to
the contributor Esther cracker well let
me start the U.S do you be waiting
patiently here
um they're the new Mandela yeah I just
find it the arrogance is incredible to
demand an apology because that's how you
get an apology by demanding one a
sincere and honest and open apology I I
just think you know they officially
declared war on the royal family by
coming out with this Netflix documentary
they made it clear that they wanted no
reconciliation because you wouldn't do
that you wouldn't put your family
through that if you really wanted right
open genuine conversation and
Reconciliation also they just called
Prince Charles A a lying bully yeah
they've called Prince William even worse
even worse so they drove him out of the
country uh with his or he drove them out
of the country with his bullying and
lies they've called the whole family a
bunch of races I would even one apology
from someone's people like that that are
so negative in your view well I think I
can understand why they're demanding
apology because they're so
self-righteous about everything they
assume they're right of everything I
can't understand what earth makes them
think Charles and William would even
consider being in the room with them
right now but I do think there's an
element of the longer that they can keep
this Feud going that's more money in
their bank account because now
everything they do they'll be oh what
about William how's your relationship
with the royal family how's your
relationship with your father and so
that's that's basically you know a giant
check that they've blank checked how
could you trust them not to just
basically record everything that goes on
if they did have a meeting like that let
me go to Natalie Collins Natalie I'm
aware there are people out there that
completely disagree and think that they
are true Freedom Fighters who were
oppressed by the royal family and have
taken their oppression now to this vast
mansion in Montecito and Santa Barbara
it's a beautiful place I've been down to
that area lovely rolling ocean waves
beautiful lifestyle um not my idea of
what oppression looks like but there we
are each to their own
um but let's get to this idea of an
apology that you can basically call a
family a bunch of callous racists who
refuse to let you get help for suicidal
thoughts that you said you you said you
had that uh made racist comments
apparently that were so demeaning you
had to allude to them on an Oprah
Winfrey interview uh you now call him a
bunch of lying bullies including the new
king why would you expect anybody to sit
down with you and apologize after you've
done all the public trashing
I think in the context of a column that
was written today by Jeremy Clarkson
which uh described Meghan Markle as
worse than Rose Weston and calling on
people to have her stripped naked and
throw excrement on her in the street I
think it's really important that we put
the context of
um what Megan and Harry are talking
about in the context of The Wider hatred
which to be fair you were a real Pioneer
in that hatred of Meghan Markle years
ago I don't hate Megan Marcus
hang on hang on well I mean
you said I hate Meghan Markle let me be
clear I've never said I hate Meghan
Markle I don't hate Meghan Markle I hate
what she's done to the royal family and
to the monarchy and to the reputation of
Britain only tonight the New York Times
has carried a major op-ed piece
absolutely trashing this country as a
racist country with a racist institution
at the head of IT a callous institution
that should be dismantled so yeah I see
real damage in what Meghan Markle and
Harry have both done now to the
reputation of his country and to our
monarchy so yeah but I don't hate them
individually as people and if you know
in relation to the Clarkston column
which he's now issued a mere culpr over
I didn't think he should have uh put
that in the column for for my personal
view but he's now said he wishes he
hadn't either so you know I don't see
what that has to do with the wider
picture of these two trashing their
families and they're demanding an
apology
well I think in the same way that you're
saying you don't personally hate them
but you are opposed to what they stand
for and what they're saying and how
they've behaved I think that's entirely
the same argument that um Megan and
Harry are making in their in their
documentary and in the work that they've
they've done is saying that actually the
way that they've been harmed by this
institution by this system which you
know we cannot deny the impact of
colonialism we can't deny the impact of
this um monarchy in terms of we have a
history in this country of doing really
terrible things for the places and to
deny that reality to deny the impact and
and the really this this month this
monarchy how is it that in this day and
age we have a group of people who are
born into wealth and privilege just
because of being born into it it is
absolutely they're also responsible for
developing the economy that's the norm
they're also responsible for developing
the Commonwealth which has been one of
the great success stories in the world
and of course it's not really
Commonwealth though is it the people
who've got that wealth are mainly in uh
the royal family have a lot more
if you hate people who've got lots of
money without actually earning or
deserving it you must also hate
therefore the sussexes who've done
nothing to deserve it other than trash
their family I just I
I think you know I I I think there's a
sense that of course people we we can't
like hate people because of their
privileged but they're what they're
doing with it or how they use a lot
utilizing it is really important as well
and I think there is a sense that we are
also talking about a a man who as a boy
his mother was killed by obeying mob in
the media and then was true I'm sorry
I'm sorry again
these are easy lies to say on television
but I'm afraid I have to hold you to a
counter it's not alive Princess Diana
was not killed by a Baby Alive princess
Diner was killed by a drunk driver that
was the official inquest report into her
death it was a drunk driver speeding who
killed Princess Diana so it wasn't yeah
you might want it to be a bane mob and
maybe Harry has grown up thinking it was
a bae mob I could tell a hundred stories
about the way his mother colluded with
me as a newspaper editor with the
paparazzi or colluded with me over
having a private lunch at Kensington
Palace giving me loads of stories which
she knew I would then have as informed
information for my newspaper I could
tell the time that Diana rang me up and
gave me an hour-long interview about a
visit to a clinic she'd done uh signed
off on every page of the interview which
was faxed to her in return with her
initials on it and the next day said she
was outraged by the intrusive story in
the Daily Mirror which was the story she
given me at length over an hour on tape
so there are lots of different ways you
can skin this cat about the relationship
between the royal family and the media
my argument about about Megan and Harry
is they apparently were so disgusted by
this callous racist family and
institution that they fled the country
gave up Royal Duty now live in
California in extreme luxury and yet
bizarrely they still want to retain the
titles afforded them by the institution
they describe as callous races and they
use those titles to make themselves
stinking rich without doing any work I
think that's hypocrisy let's go to die
Davis die Davis like the rest of the
royal family really well not really
because they do hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of Duties a year well they
turn up at 100 you know in three four
hundred events a year uh the main Royals
so they actually do put back that's the
whole point of the royal family they
don't just get paid for nothing they
give back guy Davis you were helping to
run security to royal family for many
years what do you make of this I mean I
I read this New York Times piece tonight
with a real sinking feeling in my heart
that actually the Relentless attacks by
Megan and Harry are beginning to really
stick in other parts of the world about
our country and about our monarchy
well good evening a very good friend of
mine defined ethical
being ethical means knowing what is
right and Having the courage to do what
is right
as a former policeman what I haven't
seen one iota so far is evidence and
unfortunately people like Clarkson give
Greece to the story he doesn't represent
you he doesn't represent me and he
doesn't represent 99 of this country I
take great umbrage as being classified
quite often as a police officer or an
ex-police officer as racist I resent it
and I resent those who have the audacity
to actually come out with this palable
nonsense with little or no evidence the
whole issue if they gave that 100
million to charity I'd have more respect
but I don't think they have no and you
know what though I get called a racist
all day long on social media now as a
direct result of Meghan Markle Levering
me out of my former job in which she
basically inferred if you didn't believe
her about everything you must be a
racist I don't have a racist bone in my
body nor have I ever said anything
racist about Meghan Markle no one can
find anything I've said and yet it got
so ridiculous even Sharon Osbourne was
fired from a job she loved in America
because she said I was entitled to my
opinion and for that she was called a
racist sympathizer this is how mad is
God but this is the damage that's done
the royal family right now in America
are perceived by many people to be
callous racists without any as you say
die any actual evidence to support any
of these claims and you know I mean die
on a wider point where does this leave
the molecule what should they do I mean
the historic position of the current
family is you just don't respond to this
kind of thing but are we reaching the
point and I always think that never
complain never explain is a good Mantra
the queen queen mother's mantra for
being popular in the public eye if
you're a royal but I'll be reaching a
point where they need to return some
fire
well sometimes the royal family need
good advice their Protection Officer
quite often give good advice and they
listen
in this case I don't think they should
apologize I thought they were wrong in
respect of Lady Hussey in my opinion and
a lot of people disagree she had nothing
to apologize for I felt and I said it
either on your program or others they
were wrong to jump to conclusion without
hearing all the facts and actually
interviewing lady Hussey but we are
where we are now I just hope that
doesn't set a precedent because it would
be wrong and yes would I invite them to
the coronation certainly not from a
security point of view it would all
about them and unfortunately they have
caused as I've said in the telegraph
fairly recently in my opinion there are
Nutters out there who could cause harm
to not only the royal family but also
those in America the fixated threat
assessment of the FBI and CIA and I went
to Los Angeles years ago to discuss this
they are literally thousands in America
there doing nothing to support their
safety or their cause they are
completely their moral compass has gone
ski with them well I don't think I mean
look I don't think anyone so to anyone I
don't wish any harm on any of the people
involved in this Harry Megan any of the
royal family none of them are absolutely
clearly they're going to get harm if
they carry on like this right yeah I
think all of it yeah I agree I think all
of it is incendiary and this book that's
coming out will be even more incentive
and poor even more fuel on the fire but
my question about the coronation I've
got to be honest why would two people
who despise the monarchy and everything
it stands for we think that the royal
family are a bunch of racists why on
Earth would they turn up at the
coronation
why would they I tell you why because
that's where the money is if they're
seen at the coronation next to all the
major Royal players that is gold dust
for their next Netflix series and
they're right there is the hypocrisy
that underpins everything these two do
got to leave it there a good debate
Natalie thank you very much indeed die
thank you very much